>> Bret: CLAUDIA, THANKS.
THE FOUNDER OF C-SPAN BRIAN
LAMB IS GOING OUT LIKE A LION.
HE HAS SOME PARTING TOUGH SHOTS
FOR POLITICAL WASHINGTON, THE
CITY IN WHICH HE TURNED A
UNIQUE CONCEPT INTO A MAIN STAY
OF AMERICA MEDIA.
ANALYST AND FOLKS OF FOX NEWS
"MEDIA BUZZ" HOWARD KURTZ ON
LAMB'S FINAL AND EARLY DAYS.
>> BRIAN LAMB HAD A
REVOLUTIONARY IDEA 40 YEARS AGO.
RAISE MONEY FROM CABLE
COMPANIES TO TELEVISE WHAT
CONGRESS DOES.
MINUS THE USUAL PUNDITS.
>> WE DON'T OFFER ANY ON-AIR
ANALYSIS.
NO ADS, NO PERSONALITIES, NO
RATINGS.
>> THERE WERE SOME GROWING
PAINS.
>> I APOLOGIZE FOR THE MISHAP
THERE.
SEEMS LIKE THIS BUILDING IS OLD
AND THEY WILL BE REBUILDING IT.
>> THE DAY THE SENATE GOES ON
TELEVISION, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I'LL HOLD MY BREATH FOR A
WHILE.
MIXED FEELINGS.
>> THE C-SPAN FOUNDER MADE SURE
ORDINARY CITIZENS COULD WEIGH
IN.
>> TOM, NEW YORK, BILL IN
WASHINGTON STATE, A DEMOCRAT.
>> WE CREATED A MORNING SHOW AT
C-SPAN AS A RESULT OF FRANKLY
ME AND OTHERS GROWING UP HAVING
SIXTH AVENUE IN NEW YORK AND
ABC, NBC AND CBS TALK AT US AND
NEVER LETTING ANYBODY TALK BACK.
WE WANTED WHERE SOMEBODY COULD
CALL US.
>> AND THE MUSHROOMING DEFICIT.
>> I THOUGHT CONGRESS WOULD
WASTE LESS MONEY IF THE CAMERAS
WAS ON THEM AT ALL TIME AND I
WAS DEAD WRONG.
>> A STAFFER SAID HE WAS TOLD
TO LIE ABOUT PENTAGON AS A PR
GUY AND LAMB REMAINS UPSET WITH
POLITICAL DISHON TEE.
>> I NEVER EXPECTED LYING.
IT WAS AN EDUCATION.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD
SAY IF THEY HEAR THIS HEY,
DUMMY, THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON
FOREVER.
I WAS NAIVE.
>> AT 77 HE WILL MISS HOSTING A
WEEKLY SHOW BUT LOVES COMING TO
THE OFFICE.
>> I WOULD GIVE UP SLEEPING IF
I COULD.
>> WE ALL TAKE C-SPAN FOR
GRANTED LIKE A PUBLIC UTILITY.
THE NETWORK WAS NEVER INTENDED